new york philadelphia take the jolly
ranchers out of your ears and listen up
because the keep it moving tour is
coming your way yeah guys uh it's a
stand-up show when we play ayg with the
audience it's a good time uh september
30th we're going to be in long island
and then
what are we doing if we're going home
for cheese steaks
whiz wit baby october cheese steaks and
vengeance october 27th we're going to be
at helium comedy club in philadelphia
get those tickets they're gonna move
fast i'm telling you yeah welcome to
another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r u garbage it's a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find out they grow up to be classy yeah
but they're just a big old piece of
trash oh boy i'm your host stage foley
coming at you on a glorious day we're
down here in auntie's basement was
upstairs with her we had a big breakfast
together had a burning outside bean a
bernie good job frozen pizza no big deal
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table mocking me he is the ceo of
are you garbage he's international
businessman he's got a brand new book
out right now called keep it moving the
secret to success by kevin james ryan
touring around accredited universities
sure all over the country give it up for
my best pal kevin james ryan hey gang
happy to be here thanks for tuning in as
always a little bit of business please
make sure you rate review subscribe on
itunes full video full video available
on youtube and as you know those numbers
are true true the [ __ ] roof and then
of course i'm contractually obligated to
say go to
www.patreon.com so i show you garbage
for the best patreon content in the biz
i'm going to throw it anybody praise the
lord who wants it patreon.com
amen
i can see the light baby
and how about a nice quick shout out to
our producer extraordinaire the magic
man makes us all look good the very
funny mr t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen
what up dudes hey buddy what up t-bone
i'm surprised kitty's making eye contact
now that he went all hollywood on us we
got hollywood kipp over there kid's
doing all right doing all right
with some guys on the coast
making it happen i like that true to
roof by the way thank you i like that
standard true to roof
beautiful when you do it like that you
don't want to make a media you don't
want to make it man you don't want him
making any choices do you
go with go and stay on script all right
he's made that very quickly
don't fix it you have the one weird one
true that roof something like that right
oh i like like a true
oh yeah oh man we're gonna have to cut
that
save that for the directors
that's the snyder cut over there it's a
shout out to belly gang it is a family
episode it's just us haven't done one of
these in a couple of minutes it's nice
to you know do a little house cleaning
clear out get your head straight hang
out as a family yeah it's important to
spend time as a family you got to do it
it's like sunday night dinner oh
a big big sunday night dinner guy yeah
didn't matter where the foleys were
could be scowling around in the four
corners of the county
come five o'clock sunday back locked and
loaded come running crescent rolls in
the oven
were they
i remember when i was i got old enough
to pop that oh big shot
i thought i felt like a construction
worker
snapping claymores in the jungle those
things are awesome yeah yeah sunday
dinner man in the fall
they start cooking around like two
our usual routine on sundays was pretty
tight pretty cozy yeah get up go to mass
start a fight argue in the car
come back big breakfast
little stooges
chill for a little bit maybe some leaves
some lawn this and that
and then he grows some leaves
raking some leaves
doing some yard work you don't strike me
as a yard work kid i did i've been
cutting the grass since i was maybe 10
years old that wasn't all handled by by
people
no no no no we had a we had like an og
at my mom's we had like an og you got to
think they're like between my mom and my
dad and my dad's house at my mom's house
they both blew collar my stepdad was a
construction worker my my dad was a pipe
fitter he didn't have nobody cutting the
lawn over there who you're pop my no my
i had to do the hand the push mower that
[ __ ] tattoo trick you're doing two
lawns two loans weekly since chances
yeah like salvitro and sopranos he
jumped out of a tree with a chainsaw
i got to the right to defend myself t
yeah dude the push my work [ __ ] sucks
but it's nice it's nice on the front man
not as a ten-year-old when everybody's
riding bikes and [ __ ] plane in a fire
hydrant
i'm serious to take where'd you grow up
brighton beach what are you talking
about
i was in flatbush uh everybody's on the
boards eating water ice what are you
talking about it's a picture i was
trying to paint
everyone's down there at the swimming
hole that's a tough look if you're
opening a fire hydrant in the suburbs
man no no no no no that gets shut down
real quick no but that [ __ ] suck dude
it's my dad was so
[ __ ] like ocd it's where i get it
like they ain't and dude if it was like
if you got off you had to be like
parallel and if you got off a little bit
you heard it what the [ __ ] front yard
looks like [ __ ] an old blind guy or
whatever there's a racetrack out there
oh dude i was getting my [ __ ] balls
broken i apologize then so you know yeah
[ __ ] do a little yard work do this do
that yeah nice meal i don't know
what picture you think you have of me
that i was in some ivory i could just
see you not doing that stuff i would
assume that there was there was you know
systems in place no you know i like that
i like a kid that gets his hands dirty
you actually we've never met before what
are you talking about
i know you worked with your dad and
you've done blue collar things but i
figured that your mom would have a
landscaper from jump street no no no
never that's the [ __ ] they didn't spend
money on that was like why would i pay
somebody 30 bucks i got this big hitting
i got this [ __ ] idiot dude i would
have asthma attacks every time too
nice to be on the tractor with a [ __ ]
nebulizer just [ __ ] cooking i need a
treatment
it was bad dude real tough guy huh yeah
yeah yeah all that [ __ ]
getting narcan cutting the grass jesus
christ all that [ __ ] pound and dander
reminded me of that video of uh the
reporter where the bug flies in his
mouth down there like mobile
we're down here damn country
that can be [ __ ] up about it holy [ __ ]
that's unbelievable that's what i felt
dude i would i would break out an asthma
attack almost every time the birds would
[ __ ] dive bomb the barn spot that's
where my fear of birds comes from they
didn't like me in my mom's house
yeah it was a [ __ ] scene daddy oh
chased by swallows probably at barnes
they would [ __ ] dive bomb you i know
one kid that i'd be pretty hard pressed
if he cut the grass
hill
a long hair he doesn't even cut his hair
he don't even shave his pubes this guy
he ain't doing the lawn i assume you
didn't have to do any of that stuff when
you were a kid oh yeah i did that [ __ ]
when you were home you like cutting the
grass when you were homeschooled like
just like during the middle of the week
like a retiree
is out there with a sweet tea
it's got a socks pulled up real high
gotta pick up the grandkids in an hour
so the best the best thing about cutting
the grass was
cutting the grass was big in the sense
that
if you let it go too this was as a
teenager right as a teenager everybody's
out hanging those like you you you have
the car you're driving around but you
always had that and you would always
push it like oh i'll do it tomorrow i'll
do it the next or whatever and then
somebody's like yo we're all having a
pool party over here like you keep
pushing it down and then it gets too
long then if it gets too long you got to
pick it up
you got a bag and those [ __ ] bags on
those push mowers you get about three
blades of grass in them oh well my dad's
i always had a bat he was that was but
i'm talking about my mom's it was
because i could push her sometimes i
would just do the front to keep up
appearances in the neighborhood
at least you'd be like she'd be leaving
for work at least due to the front you
[ __ ] fat pieces of [ __ ] she's like i
got i got the johnson's looking at us
like we're [ __ ] poor over here
dropping the property value yeah so it
was like at least do the front um but
then
it was you get out with the [ __ ] rake
if if you had to rake it right and get
out with the [ __ ] dude the whole
[ __ ] night oh hold on three hours
hold on a second no bag on the mower
you're just blowing and getting it into
a circle and then raking up and putting
it in [ __ ] inside trash bags that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] brutal those brown
paper bags
oh my god those things that wouldn't
stay open yeah like [ __ ] school lunch
those johns you know with your friends
drop one thing and it looks like a
[ __ ] bank it looks like money yeah
the rake would always rip the bag and
[ __ ] yeah man we had we had
poor lawn care equipment that we made do
with that's so long well and then at one
point we got rakes missing [ __ ]
bristles because [ __ ] especially my
stuff that we're not buying new stuff
kind of people we're they're not it's
like hey
my dad got something new we got the one
from the 80. like he would be like oh my
dad got this or my brother got or
something or we just cleaned out my
parents garage there's a [ __ ] level
in there that they must have used for
the [ __ ] empire state
it's got to be made of pure lead it says
noah on it
bonkos um
but well i wanted to say one we got the
sweeper he came home with the sweeper
one that you would hook up to the back
and it would and throw it in the so
you're driving with like a trailer on
like a little hitch oh you gotta [ __ ]
brushed it up into the thing oh you got
a rope you dumped that and [ __ ] keep
[ __ ] cooking
like you're playing with your tonka
trucks as a kid i felt real official
with that [ __ ] thing
you know it was the most legit thing
remember they had a little bulldozer at
playground sometimes it had a little
scoop on it and you can sit on it and
pull the [ __ ] out bigger oh that blew my
mind that was like great adventure i was
like going to [ __ ] disney world to me
getting on that thing a couple hours on
the bobcat
clear my head a little bit oh all right
yeah it's family episode family about
the family yeah so as you know you sign
up for patreon mm-hmm all right we're
going to be answering your questions
we're going to be doing that right here
before we get started nice quick shout
out send some love jace out there in
wisconsin jason a family in wisconsin
shout out to you boom yeah
uh let's see here let's this is a
perfect one perfect perfect perfect
transition uh this is from suds on as
you guys know what did you say we do it
we're doing pretty good as you know did
you as you know when you're doing the
patreon did you run through that yet
already just did it okay i'm sorry sorry
sign up for the patreon we answered one
of your questions on the air a bit of a
backlog as kippy says i'm turning into a
company man we're pretty caught up at
this point we're pretty good we're
pretty good we're not too far we're not
too far behind ever since i got on the
team yeah um all right this one's from
suds uh hey boys real classy gentlemen
mr suds hey boys did your dad ever put a
wet hat in the freezer to wear while he
was mowing the lawn
talking about bringing the core temp
down holy [ __ ] that's genius that's
really good the only time i ever saw
that was uh we were going out golfing
like a couple like maybe a decade ago me
all my uncles and cousins and stuff and
my aunt was like
i put you frozen rags in a cooler i put
and we were like shot up with these
frozen rags lady old bird until you get
out there until we hit about like the
seventh hole dude everybody was fighting
over them like shawshank yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it was fantastic that that
takes you down to the dude that'll
that'll cool you to the core it's great
yeah it's great i don't want to bring up
college football but i'm gonna but we
had these huge buckets that had
thousands i so want obviously yeah
you're this world-renowned you know uh
d3 college player i still want to just
i'm connecting to you with the story
about it
i so just want to see tape and just hope
you're just getting laid out every play
you're fumbling [ __ ] your shoes are
untied you know we could do well a
couple of bucks now we can spring for
some athletic equipment and you can get
out there and line up okay
see if you can get past me where are
denny's what are you talking about
we'll find a field get past you yeah
okay would that be would that be fun
he'll walk three steps to the left i
could roll under your leg between your
legs if i went woody i don't know okay
i'll untie your shoe i'll have you
looking for a park bench
if you don't have a shoe horn he's
screwed son of a [ __ ]
coach i'm out
um no dad never did that he did do the
handkerchief
but not in the freezer we weren't we
there was no clothes being put in the in
the refrigerator or the freezer nothing
like that she didn't go for that [ __ ]
sure that feels like a garage fridge
move yeah that's for grocery and jewelry
an important document
these are birth certificates in the
crispers i remember being a weird kid i
had i had like a favorite t-shirt
as i was i'm talking like young like
five like a like babyish like one of my
first memories i had a gi a tan gi joe
t-shirt that i just i like it i would
wear every to the point where i was like
we gotta wash it and i would just like
wait by the washer for it to come out
yeah talk about attachment issues jesus
christ
holy is you have a whoopi or anything
like that i have a whoopee
i've heard my my buddy used to say will
be and he had it till we were like 24.
i moved in with my buddy
dude i moved in with my buddy and he
brought his whoopi and i was like dude
this can't happen you're not gonna the
[ __ ] chicks are gonna be coming over
with you and your [ __ ] whoopie
yeah you're trying to get laid here dude
you're trying to get laid you got the
whoopie up because listen i sucked my
thumb for a long
time something else
i don't know what to tell you
i am who i am
i saw how long
oh dude like sixth grade
what yeah and you're calling me [ __ ]
up
i wasn't waiting at the spin cycle for
my i mean i was excited for my jam jams
to come out i was exaggerated
but it got to a point where like they
stayed they started implementing dental
procedures to get me to stop cause like
once it went like they're trying to fix
my overbite and stuff because then it
wouldn't fit in there nicely anymore
yeah
i haven't i have an overbite now yeah
yeah yeah you didn't wear the things
they were like hey you want to do it i'm
like nah i'm cool with this but that's
if you got an underbite you gotta take
care of it dude you got an underbelly a
british lord
yes
you look like a trout
you look like a walleye pike
um
but that that
i understand that that that's trash
sucking your thumb but you know what's
really garbage people that sucked their
fingers and had whoopies
suck their fingers you never saw
somebody suck their fingers instead of
their thumb it's alien i don't know the
even the the thumb even like all the
kids no one's was really a a thumb
kind of guy really yeah no hmm
any other quirks twirling the hair or
anything like that no
no no no my brother used to bounce his
head at night
bounces like while he was sleeping his
head would be bouncing
[Laughter]
and i used to love sleeping in there
because it was like sleeping in a
massage chair because like he was what
are you in the bed with him i used to
sleep with him all the time in bed yeah
you're [ __ ] up
i was when i was a little kid i was
scared and they're sucking each other's
thumbs
you suck mine i'll suck you away
yeah i dude i used to be so scared at
night like going into my room i would
still say you're paranoid i think it's
like i think it's only gotten worse
ladies and gentlemen this guy holds it
together for two hours a week but once
the lights turn down and the lens caps
goes on this guy's [ __ ] bonkers
that's just scary that's that's a sad
thought it wasn't that i was scared of
the dark i was having anxiety yeah you
were paranoid yeah i remember my dad i
was i was i'm anxious now it's gotten
better obviously you know it's
definitely gotten better and i'm
checking it and stuff but i remember my
dad i was panicking one time in the club
about something and my dad goes yeah
you're just a weary ward and i'm like
looking back i'm like not really swept
out under the rug we we could have
addressed this at eight and out of my
twenties would have been decent could
have dropped a hundred on a therapist
yeah i'd still have a hairline i'm
[ __ ] wearing this thing out
yeah we had us we had this we shared a
room for a while when we first moved
down to philly i loved it we shared a
room even though uh senator had a guest
room we still shared a room bunk beds
yeah set it up nice toys under the beds
everything's clean nice radio [ __ ]
fantastic yeah good times um
all right let's see here this one's from
ulysses uh
garbage after dark question
hit the music
uh have you ever worn sweat slash
basketball shorts to the strip club so
the stripper can feel up on your hoagie
[Laughter]
uh no no i have heard that tip before
from a couple of old timers to like you
wear dress pants when you wear like suit
pants because it's real thin and you can
you know there's there's more friction
apparently i don't know i don't i don't
freak with i don't frequent these kind
of places no i don't got that kind of
hoagie either
i i always i always steer traffic away
from down there
hey why don't you concentrate on the
feet toots
you gotta fun-size snickers yeah there's
no free samples no
you buy it how you saw it it's like i'm
like carmax
order that [ __ ] up online yeah you get
it when you get it three days delivery
it's like [ __ ] groundhog's day my guy
sold his shadow he's coming back in i'm
an ambusher
now you see me
yeah no thanks
um i have heard that before an old boss
told me that yeah and as a heavier guy
sometimes like your pants like oh boy
are like poking out so like you would
squeak there'd be nothing there anyway
yeah because your pants as a as a bigger
guy your pants are lower on your body so
there's more uh there tends to be more
jock
area it's more crop like where your mom
used to be like there's too much room in
the crotch
somebody grabs down there there's just
nothing
hey
they made me check it at the door i
don't know what to tell you
here's my ticket go ask for number 72.
get the party started yeah yeah no
thanks um yeah the la i haven't been to
one in years but i was all bombed up
i think it was like my bachelor party or
whatever
and somebody was like i'm not a laptop
silk onesie
like i'm trying to get your rubble i got
my silk boxers on for when i was trying
to get your rub on that's real trashy
though um no trying to catch a free nut
at the [ __ ]
basketball shorts
no i went the one time i was at uh not
showing that he wanted another dance
show-and-tell
and uh we were kid like not kids
whatever you know early 20s or where
college maybe and this stripper came up
and she's like hey how about a dance i
just didn't have money but i'm trying to
keep up allures you know what i mean of
like ah no i'm alright maybe late you
know type thing i'm sure you really got
in her head
and she's like uh
she's like why hey why not i'm like yeah
you know just whatever something
something she's like she's like i know
what's wrong i'm like oh what's that
she's like you're gonna come too fast
i'm like what yeah just go in the
bathroom and jerk off real quick i'm
like is that what people are doing in
here what the [ __ ]
i'm not using the sink when i go back in
there
well i just brushed my teeth in there
[Music]
yeah i was like jesus christ people are
doing any animals in here kippy let's
talk about lace weights again love those
guys love those folks over there at
lathe weights i like a glass of wine i
like i like having the guesswork
taken out and done for me i like people
to say this is a good one this is a good
one but who are you going to trust i'll
tell you you're going to trust who
you're going to call who you're going to
text you're going to text the good
people at lace weights and get a nice
box of wine yeah uh wine description
lathe weights wine subscription is an
easy way to bring exciting new wines
right to your doorstep unbox a world of
wine with easy access to different and
unexpected winemakers from all over the
globe how many bottles you get how many
bottles do you get when you sign up six
you get six bottles plus two free bonus
bottles what two free stemless wine
glasses all just for the price of 49.99
with free delivery and all you got to do
is what text them you text garbage to 64
000 everything comes right up it's easy
peasy uh lathe weights taste over 40 000
wines a year
but only 600 make the cut so you enjoy
the cream of the crop
best of the best
uh you get 100 satisfaction guarantee
subscriptions are flexible all they make
it easy for you and there's no
commitment to continue cancel online
whenever you want uh coolest thing to me
because i always feel like a bozo when
i'm out ever ordering a glass of wine i
don't know what i'm talking about
gives you a little knowledge hbox comes
with no like tasty notes for you food
pairing tips serving inspiration you
want to sound good if you're out to
dinner and you know something someone's
like i'm getting the fish you go whoo
get that seemed like a scene you want to
play and i saw the on blanc with that
yeah yeah yeah from new zealand so guys
one more time
uh
you get six bottles six amazing bottles
of wine plus two bonus bottles and two
stemless wine glasses 49.99 plus tax
with free delivery just text garbage to
64 000 to get the special offer one more
time garbage to 64 000 terms apply
available at laceweight.com
do it hey gang i want to talk to you
about myfitnesspal our brand new sponsor
here on the show uh
as of recently i've put on a lot of
weight and i see myself in clips and on
the show and pictures of myself and it
hits me i gotta do better i gotta
figure this out i gotta lose the weight
i gotta get healthy and i know finding
the motivation to work out and eat
healthy has always been a struggle for
me and a lot of people i know the big
man struggles obviously
and my fitness pal is trying to change
that for us it's not a rigid diet plan
you learn
from your personalized data what works
best for you your version of healthy
might be different from my version of
healthy which might be different from
the big man's version of healthy and
that's fine myfitnesspal helps you
figure out what is best
for you
and myfitnesspal you're not doing it
alone you have access to guided daily
workouts meal plans written by
dietitians and exercise scientists
plus support from other members with
shared goals and experiences so uh my
fitness pal does way more than just
count calories it's not just one of
those apps you download for free by
banging by the boom you get support you
need to meet your health goals you can
unlock the amazing things myfitnesspal
can do like me and the big man
uh you start your premium membership
today go to
garbage.myfitnesspal.com and use promo
code garbage to get a one month premium
membership for free that's garbridge
garbage dot m y f i t n e s s p a l dot
com code garbage for a free one month
premium membership baby
garbage.myfitnesspal.com do it folks
this podcast is brought to you by the
good people that better help gang mental
health is a very important issue and if
you're having some trouble you're having
some problems something's holding you
back from living a full complete healthy
and happy life reach out to the folks
that better help they can really take
care of you it's not a self-help line
all right it's not a crisis hotline
you're talking about licensed therapists
that you can talk to in the privacy of
your own home you send a message you get
a response within 48 hours from a
licensed professional therapist and
they're there to help you yeah guys
doesn't matter where you are in the
country in the world uh it's easy peasy
service is available to everybody it's
more affordable than traditional offline
counseling and financial aid is
available if you may need it better help
want you to start living a happier life
today
uh and they really do because it's not
all it's it's not all for show they
offer financial assistance if you need
help yeah okay you might not have the
kind of therapist in your hometown sure
that they can offer of course different
specialists different this different
that
um
you can visit betterhelp.com
garbage that's better help help and join
over one million people have taken
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional uh
special offer for are you garbage
listeners you get 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com garbage that's
betterhelp help.com
garbage now back to the show
oh that's [ __ ] good feeling up on a
hoagie shout out to the hoagie crushers
too fantastic
um
all right let's see here
uh this is from uh sammy samuel i'll
call them
um are you garbage if the high school if
your high school made everyone take a
yellow bus to prom because there was too
much drunk driving going on in the town
what the [ __ ] i guess they all got
together and like we're not even letting
in order to go to prom you got to take
the bus we're not even risking it
did you guys what we used to do they
used to put the smashed up car on the
property oh yeah and yeah one flipped
upside down they did a whole show yeah
yeah yeah
the dead girls hanging out the window
and the kids we didn't see that i think
they pulled they realized that was a
little too way too much and they pulled
back on that because i think my brother
had that and then like the in the
five-year period by the time i got there
was like yeah this is a little too fast
i remember when i first got into high
school i got i my first year of high
school was
1989 or 1990
and for those seniors that year yeah
they had like they probably sacrificed
something yeah it was like corpses
drinking all over the [ __ ] high
school that [ __ ] was [ __ ] yeah we did
limos like we said i've we've said
before limos was the big thing everybody
chipped in like 40 bucks and you put 30
people in a [ __ ] limo yeah we drove
ourselves as we said and like three of
my friends all got duis
so i can see it what kind of parenting
and like policing was going on in that
town that they would like the school had
to step in and be like they're like look
these kids are drunk and i'm not gonna
be a narc about it yeah and i'll tell
you what it makes sense and if i was in
if i was in high school i would think it
was actually all right who gives a [ __ ]
we're all in the same thing yeah that's
that's what i'm saying that's pretty
cool if you're just getting a cool boss
maybe some bernie's out the back some
bernie's at the back if you're gonna get
your drink on you're getting your drink
on you don't gotta [ __ ] worry about
it nothing's nothing too crazy is gonna
happen yeah i like that approach i love
it now i'm borderline on the well i'd
rather have them do it here than do it
out there those parents were using a
little sheisty
of course yeah of course they used to
run a very local uh thing in my i don't
know if it was like you know for bucks
county or even philadelphia but it was
like
a bad tv
like a bad movie like the lifetime of
what they made it was like
a thing on like hey don't do this and it
was bad actors of like a parents who
like hey i'd rather you do it here
everybody put your keys in the basket or
whatever and you can drive home in the
morning type thing this was a production
that you saw yeah it was they used to
run it on like the local channel like
num the channel nine or something really
and i used to it was so i used to watch
it because it was so cringe-worthy
that's trash yeah yeah yeah they would
be like hey don't be these parents don't
be the cool you think you're being the
first parent that that [ __ ] was still
going on because when i was little local
programming was big and that's where you
saw some weird [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah weird [ __ ] that's this was
kind of yeah this is filming in a
[ __ ] studio in norristown somewhere
exactly yeah it was like this real it's
like a high school production
even worse sometimes just a bald guy
popping balloons like what is this dude
it's a kid show
oh all right this one's from alessandro
do you put ice in your orange juice i
feel you're probably very opinionated on
this
oh
do i put ice
in my i'm going i'm going to i'm going
to staunch no if it's cold
you know if you're trying to get a if
it's if you're pulling it out of the
fridge absolutely not if you're
somewhere maybe at like a buffet or
something got it out maybe a little bit
just to [ __ ]
just to get it towards screaming you
know what i mean other than that
absolutely not here's the water down a
product i need it screaming
i want to get that on the table
most beverages
that's the final the first rule of
business it's got to be screaming 32.5
is where i like it at okay freezing
now the only time that i would do that
again
exactly what you're saying all right if
i go to a buffet
there's o.j that's sitting in the
pitcher i got to fully ice it up however
i'll only do that for fresh squeeze
orange juice if it's just regular i'm
not going to [ __ ] with if it's warm
because the ice isn't really going to
help it but the ice does make fresh
squeeze real real classy i'll give you
that because
fresh squeeze is a little thick too so
you can well you're thinner thinner i've
known
yeah
it's like a cocktail you put do yourself
a favor you want to make a little
[ __ ] drink fresh squeezed orange
juice couple splashes of club soda some
crushed ice and a [ __ ] rocks glass
seems like a lot for a [ __ ] orange
juice huh
some people like to live man
some people like to live okay
i'm a saunch no on that you shouldn't be
[ __ ] do that and milk no i've done it
in milk isis for [ __ ] soda
that's about it
i'll give you that
water
which i'm not a fan of but water other
than that i like ice water yeah
i was really good last night i was at
the i was at the club and uh
at levy live and you have free
access to the fountain sodas
[Music]
and they got dude they have these big
like
those it's shaped like a beer can the
glass you know what i mean it's got that
like lip that goes up okay you know what
i mean yeah yeah yeah it's like shaped
like a can i got it big it's like a
[ __ ] you know like a 20 ounce oh i
know exactly oh it looks like something
out of like a science lab yes like a
beaker it's very big oh i love that dude
get that i got the scoop big thing of
ice [ __ ] diet coke i'm doing ice cold
screaming ice cold water out of that
thing it was [ __ ]
for some reason i feel cool with that
track really important trashy dreams
would be to have one of those in your
house a [ __ ] just old fashioned yeah
you gotta have a closet with all the
[ __ ] bags of [ __ ] syrup in there
you gotta do it hey where's someone
change the sprite you can only do three
what are you having
i can [ __ ] coke zero coke zero diet
coke and coke zero again
in case the gas right in case you run
out i don't want to be switching every
day yeah i don't need anything else
that's it i'm not a sprite guy anymore
i'm a dumb d i'm a dumb i'm a dc guy
maybe a diet dr pepper i've been
dabbling in
yeah they're classy get two screaming
cold cans right it's like dessert diet
doctor
it's like a sundae
[Laughter]
all right this one is uh this one's from
tj
ever ever gone on your lunch break from
work to a sam's club or costco food
court
which i don't that's garbage that's
trash but
probably pretty good
it's i know i know uh costco has a
that's like frozen p
that's a tough look
in there i know that reminds me you have
to have a membership to get into the
food court or can anybody go in there is
that open to the public i don't know is
that open to the public
the vip yeah because if you're just
getting a sam's club card just so you
can have lunch there well it also
depends on proximity listen when you're
working say you got a half hour or an
hour or whatever camped up you can be
and it's like if you're in the city it's
one thing so this guy's clearly not in
the city because there's no sam's clubs
in the middle of [ __ ] chicago i would
assume you know or like downtown places
so it's like this guy's probably in a
more suburban area so there's not
something close
back if this is like across the street
and you're like dude i'm hemmed up it's
going to be 15 minutes for me to get to
the pizza place and then i only have 10
minutes to eat then i got to get back
they can [ __ ] the whole whatever this
might be the thing yeah cause i used to
go to this i used to eat a lot of corn
dogs though i used to eat at a grocery
store
those aren't bad however you do not feel
great when you see people in the lounge
area or the cafe area of a grocery store
you do say to yourself what are you
doing i i
i do my best work in those air a lot of
times i'm at that bar or at the table i
spend a lot of [ __ ] sometimes if you
catch it at the right time you're
rolling there around 11 or 12 12 o'clock
and they got the hot bar going though
you nut listen little chicken cacciatore
i'm the king of the hot bar in new york
city you want a good hot bar you get
i'll tell you wherever the [ __ ] they're
done it's over it's over some people are
still pushing it with you no more hot
bars no more buffets no more [ __ ]
salad bars i our parents love the good
salad bar yeah yeah they knew what they
were doing back then
80 to 96 i would say
salad bar ruled that was the cream of
the crop for the salad they really had
their shine i remember when it changed
on me it was kind of it was right before
the pandemic but it changed of
i was always big because you can eat
healthy at a hot bar get a couple pieces
of chicken or like you know some
whatever and a cup a little bit of
vegetables and it's like you know
whatever you're out the door you're
eating relatively healthy yeah [ __ ] all
that nonsense i'm getting [ __ ]
general sounds chicken and some mac and
cheese yeah lasagna and mashed potatoes
oh i love those combinations they're
great for sure that's why i love a
buffet of vfw because meatballs are
mashed potatoes together meatballs
mashed potatoes and coleslaw i'm happy
with a nice dinner roll and all the
valor you can steal
[Laughter]
you're in your dress blues
um
i uh
what the [ __ ] oh so it was before the
panda because i got cold on the hot bars
just because i didn't realize
that
food is just out there for anybody you
know i think everybody operates under
the same thing as i do and then this i
was in the department are you nuts and
dude there's
homeless people are coming in just
probably grabbing handfuls of mac and
cheese as they're walking by i saw a guy
put his hand and grab meatballs out and
i was just like i ate those meatballs
yesterday oh my god stuck it in like the
just his hand right grabbed like three
meatballs and walked out
and i was like i'm never going to eat
from one of these hot bars again ugh
yeah
yeah thinking that's happening probably
10 times a day at each place
people breathing on it huffing on its
knees yeah you don't think he's circling
back to get some dessert also too like
he probably
he probably regularly does that you know
what i mean that's not his f i didn't
just randomly catch this guy on his
first time pocketing some meatballs yeah
this wasn't a first offense
getting cold on the hot bar sounds like
a springsteen
this one
this one
all right this is gonna be a divisive
one for sure with the audience i can
feel it
um
this guy's i mean you got steve you got
liquid coming out of every orifice at
all times
oh jesus christ he's gonna can put it on
my face no he's currently wiping himself
with a lysol [ __ ]
thing that we use to clean the bathroom
that's clean
man
what kills all the germs what are you
talking about
they're all hand wipes now after the
pandemic i don't give a [ __ ] um they're
all hand wipes okay as long as there's
no bleach in it
i don't like salt lysol doesn't [ __ ]
with bleach
i don't know it's just lemon and natural
i would probably say don't put in your
mouth i would kill 99 of viruses and
bacterias and foleys
um all right this one's going to be
device i don't under i don't know let's
see this is from ddot to general um
it's more of a statement if you put your
pants on before your socks like a third
grader you need help and should seek
therapy that's crazy socks go on first
no that's what he's saying
if you put he's saying if you put your
pants on before your socks yeah you need
therapy
and i'm saying you put your socks on
before your pain that's what he's saying
yeah i agree with him that's nuts
that's crazy dude
no that's crazy wait hold on you put
your pants on then your socks yes 100 oh
that's cookie talk why would you do that
then you have to bend over in your pants
what why that makes sense so yours is
yours like uh
bend over in your pants that you're i
think you're saying that's more
strenuous
i mean i don't know personally well i
that's what i'm saying i never thought
about ohio but yes to answer your
questions i have to bend over in my
pants that's not like a a thing i'm i'm
dreading every day but okay my
situation notwithstanding aside however
uh you did that all growing up
maybe not when i was a kid i don't know
i was reckless back then
i was a wild child put on a sock and a
shoe yeah then you're crazy oh yeah yeah
people have talked socks are part of the
undergarment which would be
socks the underwear the t-shirt they
that'll that first that's part of the
first layer that all goes on first
then you put your pants and your shoes
and your shirt on no shirts always last
that's absolutely that's that is 100
volts
okay so the sod the socks not an under
an undergarment considering it goes into
a shoe are you just walking out with
your socks on kevin
no but you also put shirt in the socks
category which is an outside doesn't go
into nothing i said t-shirt if you have
a t-shirt on i'm
just his formal dress
yeah formal dresses if i'm i'll put if
i'm putting i don't know
dude i can't doesn't make sense yeah it
doesn't make sense hard my mind is being
blown right now that anyone would ever
you were homeschooled you don't know
what's going on
i'm on a bad team right here yeah get
out of here no i would have to argue
that
it doesn't
it doesn't make sense to me it just
wouldn't feel right putting socks just
standing there in socks and underwear
it's a great feeling just doesn't makes
in my brain it's a great feeling
no you're crazy i don't know what to
tell you
you have to put no you put your it goes
underwear
pants
socks
yeah that's it that's that's that's the
order i mean you live your life you do
what you you know you do what you want
but
i can't be involved in it
huh crazy talk sucks first socks then
pants is like guys who work at pawn
shops [ __ ] like they're just like dirt
bags that's crazy to me
well if it's if it's a formal affair if
you're putting a suit on you're
definitely putting the socks on first
because they got to go all the way up
right
that i'll that sammy thrusting that damn
it that'll end up socks on yeah that's
different though we're talking suits
you're talking you wear shorts most days
you wear you wear the same pair of
champion basketball shorts from the 80s
most days so like don't be dropping sam
ace rosting on me okay
that's crazy
yeah
i don't know we're gonna have to
everybody chime in i i don't know where
this falls socks on for you put your
socks on with your underwear
all right i'll give you that that's an
easy roll then socks yeah get out of the
shower dry off
brush your teeth all that stuff put your
socks in your underwear see i think this
is what you're accompanying it with
underwear i don't to me i can't tell you
not
i'm i'm explaining
uh to me i go
that is
that goes on before my that's connected
to my shoes a little bit the underwear
no the socks oh hugo underwear shoes so
listen if you hold on socks on the
outside if you're not if you're getting
ready in the morning right and you're
not going anywhere you're just say you
sleep naked right you get up
you put a pair of underwear on and a
pair of basketball shirts you also put
on socks to walk around the house
no
case in point
so you already have shorts on or so i'm
also not putting shoes on
that's my point exactly so then i put
them on secondly no yes socks just
proved my point the socks are part of
the undergarment for when you're going
up do the socks not are the socks not an
undergarment
sure there you go they go but you just
said you don't put them on if you're not
leaving the house so i also don't put a
bathing suit on if i'm not swimming
what's the difference that's that and
the house is different who put socks on
to walk around the house what are you a
psycho that's what i'm saying so what so
if you there were
so what's i'll tell you one time i put
pants on either
i'm in my apartment shorts or underwear
or alfresco
i'll lock hard
all right we're gonna i gotta we we need
a bigger sample size than this and i
need some more reason so chime in let us
know what you [ __ ] think socks first
remember that that's my campaign pled
socks first ladies and gentlemen team
pants yeah that's nuts to me good
socks are like the last thing i do
yeah socks are the last thing i do for
sure
this guy was cutting his grass at four
in the afternoon
just siding with him with the mid julia
yeah good luck
socks first
bananas
all right let's see here this one's from
brooklyn uh
hey y'all been a patron for about four
months finally thought of a question i'm
a big fan of eddie's like foley oh
loving eddie but this one has yeah
ever eaten a hard candy that are so old
they're not hard anymore
they do reach they do get ripe let me
tell you something i prefer it
you can hit certain ones at certain
times it's like a wine like it gets to a
point where you go oh this is i've
perfect i've reached a point you pull
out like an old werther's or something
caramel oh that gets the edges on it if
it's been in a car for a little too long
in the summer maybe i love that yeah
that's all right i absolutely love that
yeah you know what i'm like getting a
taffy and a hard candy all at once i'm
always reminded of those uh the
strawberry things that are little red
john's the little strawberry it's look
even the wrapper looks like of course
yeah we've talked about it yeah those
age pretty well yeah
that'll get a little soft but still hard
to it
i love that like a soft batch
put those in the sun pull that out of a
dusty glass dish yeah
clean living
plus they have the you know that's one
of the only one of the candies as an
under wrapper too has a little wax a
little wax class classy classic they
know what they're doing every day it's a
strawberry
the strawberry factory
um this one's from corey ever use your
foot to put down the toilet seat so you
don't have to wash your hands after you
pee
i've been doing just uh
hand sanitizer
i'm not washing my hands in a bathroom
now i'm not public bathrooms no public
bathrooms i don't [ __ ] with i'll hit the
[ __ ] i'll hit double dose of the hand
sanitizer on my way out it's also too
like i'm not touching much i'm not going
in i'm not like sometimes i'm like you
hit you got to hit the soap or like if
it you got to hit the the sink and i'm
going and let me tell you if you think
that's dirtier my hands are now dirtier
than they were
after me just peed yes and i'll say this
okay i'll admit this if you think i'm
bad at home with the dribbling on on the
seat when i'm in a public place or
something i've shared bathrooms with you
yeah i'm
i don't i'm in and out it's like a guy
trying to control a fire hose
oh i'm putting i'm not doing the
reconstruction i'm putting out the fire
and leaving yeah yeah you're not worried
about cleanup no yeah you're there to do
one job and that's pee on the seat these
aren't smart bombs i'm dropping
collateral
[Laughter]
collateral damage is to be expected uh
yeah that's i'm
i'm i never touched the toilet seat
really i'll try to put it up if it's if
there's no pee on the seat
i'll try to be respectful i'm not just
going to celebrate it oh yeah if it's if
i'm walking into somewhat of a clean
situation but if somebody already
started to charge yeah i'm not going to
be the one [ __ ] a rest stop too rest
stops are fair [ __ ] game yeah and
we're not picking up trash on the
highway we've been drunk we've been
driving around we've been you know shows
and stuff we've been in the car hitting
rest stops in different states like i
don't know what's go i don't know if
it's like
the smell in there oh dude and every
toilet is like over i've like peed like
to like overflow a toilet you know what
i mean you're like what the [ __ ] who's
no i don't know if anybody's nobody's
checking what's going on over there yeah
i'm out where was the place we were at
that bath mats at the urinals that [ __ ]
was gross i don't know that
i don't know it's bad a lot of them are
i've seen yeah i've seen that i've seen
like they have the they'll put like that
black carpet it's like industrial car
you're like dude this thing's just got
to be
[ __ ] soaked and pee-pee right now
dude it smells like a puppy
yeah it's tough
um that and like the random scales
that'll be in truck stops yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
scale
um
all right let's see here uh
this is from smart it haven't had one
red and this is perfect ever had
mirrored sunglasses which i think you
just bought just bought
big man's rolling around hollywood
success is going through his head he's
got his movement watch
clear ray-ban boyfriends they're called
called boyfriends that's the style
they're clear plastic mirrors
fake yeah for sure fake not at all it's
a lie
i checked everything those are those are
really bands
laugh it all don't be a [ __ ] at roy
bands oh come on get out of here you're
so sensitive about these sunglasses but
they're just they're exactly the same
trust me i'm roy
listen i'm roy my brother's ray they're
the same glasses with different names
it's the same actually
we're cousins
it's fine
i'm passing the savants onto you
he spends all his money on marketing
i cut out the middleman there's only one
glass in here
be okay just squint don't worry about it
dude roy band
pretty good
yeah
it's okay
okay
now they're not fake though see
dude because i said it to you joking
around in a like in a drunk comment i
want the american people we worked out
no i'm not walking around as fake
rapists we woke i woke up the next
morning and the freezer you don't think
these are fake do you like you were like
standing over my bed
you don't want to use your fake do you
well they also sold funnel cake where i
bought it i know
you bought them from like
the sketchiest spot oh i bought them
from a legit surf shop dude there's no
first of all there's no legit surf shop
on wildwood's boardwalk there's nothing
legit except sam's pizza dad oakley's
shout out to it
you ain't lying sister i'll tell you
that uh yeah they're just not uh that's
yeah i don't know i wouldn't
i wouldn't spend any money on investing
in anything over 20 bucks on on the
boardwalk
interesting it's like a corny these are
corny folks
you don't know what you're getting
gypsies bad meat and fake ray-bans
travelers travelers travel storefronts
just hooked up to a wagon just pulls
away
you're in it
does sam's pizza stay open all year
uh no they're later and earlier but not
all year okay you know they might open
it like easter and then they'll do like
the weekends and when people start going
down and stuff like that
um why you want to go grab a slice
i'm thinking about it all right this
one's from dakota child never had a
question read you might be able to shine
some light i got nothing i'm in the dark
here on this establishment is it garbage
to love red robin just for the unlimited
steak fries
never been never been but i just learned
they have unlimited steak fries and
that's right up hippies
i gotta be honest with you big fan of
the steak fries
man yeah i would think in order done
well all things being equal in a vacuum
perfect world
steak fry
steak fries is the cut right the cut
then the waffles they're tough
a lot of people don't do them right
though a lot of people um they're
undercooked a lot of places in the
middle and that's the problem yeah i
don't know if the grease is too hot or
whatever but it's not freezing too hot
if the grease is too hot they'd be
cooked perfect yeah but if it was lower
and longer it would be okay the
outside's getting cooked because it's
warm dan mcdonald i've watched [ __ ]
you just watched the founder
they do that same thing i did but i
didn't pull that's common knowledge if
you put a frozen pizza in the oven at 6
000 degrees it's to knock a cook on the
middle i like it a little crispy
i like a little burnt sitting there with
a blow torch
i think it's creme brulee
um steak fries waffle fries
then those uh crinkle cuts
or ida
really yeah or ida potatoes organ it's
o-r-e-i-d-a oregon idaho look at the
brain on youtube you really are an
international business hello that's
that's what they tell you that the g2
summit
the six sigma summit
there's six sigmas you're out of
bilderberg or whatever it's called build
a bear build a bear
i went to school with build-a-bear
uh
i think you've overstepped one huge
the sweet potato fry the tater tot no
get out of here you're all missing
you're missing one
that's to me curly come on curly's
girlies curly's for [ __ ] carnies and
gypsies curly's all right on the
boardwalk on the boardwalk get good
curly fries
or like a winged spot typically has good
i'm not saying they're fantastic but i'm
saying to get them that's where you get
them
you're to me you're missing one there's
also my deli makes a [ __ ] fantastic
early frog
fantastic
shout out to the oasis deli
the two palm trees you're missing a big
one in my book
the steak that goes on that goes under
the that goes that flies under the radar
not the [ __ ] with the krabby stuff on it
those chicky and peat fries they could
take a hike crab fries are fantastic get
out of here with that crap
it's just french fries with old days all
bait chips too hit the bricks i'm sorry
i'm telling you right now you're nuts
hit the bricks beer battered i'm a big
beer batter fry guy oh i know what
you're talking about where they have
like the little crocodile yeah come on
those done right and i [ __ ]
put a nice crisp thing of chicken
tenders
screaming wild cherry pepsi you like dip
those in the
beer ketchup fry to me hands down tip
hands down beer batter fry all right
wins not even close but here's the thing
those those are the cheapest and the
trashiest they can always be done wrong
or be stale what the beer batter
i don't know i i've i've never had a bad
beer batter fry that's where i'm that's
my stance on it interesting very
interesting
the crinkle cut kick right i need
something crispy on the outside i love
the crinkle cut and let me tell you
something if you're out there in the
burbs and they have nathan's fries in
your grocer's freezer get those bring
them home throw them on an old cookie
sheet you know what was great i'm trying
to pull up a picture of it we grown up
they were called i think they were
called tasty fries oh yeah i know
exactly like a brown and black bag they
were in a really thin frozen bag sure
my dad used to throw those on a [ __ ]
you know they throw those on a [ __ ]
baking sheet that's what i'm talking
about perfectly like
perfectly you can really do wonders with
frozen [ __ ] in the oven yeah you gotta
know what you're doing throw some fish
sticks some dude come on
[ __ ] tight
um ma'am
i would never hit a red robin we can
find one on the road that'd be a good
[ __ ] 100 percent i would have raised
i hear good things about their burgers
yeah again that's like the sonic the
commercials we've been seeing our whole
lives i've never [ __ ] come across i
think there's a couple by the malls
where i grew up like in that shop until
there was a red rob like i've seen them
i think there is one off the turnpike
going towards the chamonix now that i
think of it yeah i used to see it over
the trees
i see him robin he's red
or it was like an a w
we used to drive by that like it was the
taj mahal like whenever it's like a fast
food place that you know you don't you
don't get to [ __ ] with that cruise buy
one of those the a w well there was one
in a shamany mall that wasn't in really
it wasn't in the food court
it was like over by pennies or something
and you were like what it was like next
to a pet shop i'm like this ain't
[ __ ] appetizing dude nashamity sounds
made up
shenanigan
uh yeah how many more tough look man i
remember being alive i mean
pet shops are gross we walked in i was
like i'll get this get that i was like i
got a hot dog i need a hot dog at the
mall like a [ __ ] jerk-off i'm like
what are we doing here
um
all right let's see this is more
i'll defer to you most food questions i
you know i tend to defer to you big head
questions excellent or anything about
rogaine i tend to jump hit me go ahead
um
this is from geronimo have you ever
eaten a lone condiment as a snack
maybe like a dab of barbecue sauce
spoonful of hot sauce
something to wet the beak a little bit
take the edge off
i used to eat relish
yeah that's bad that's you know what was
like a spoon
just made my [ __ ] blood run a good a
fresh thing of sweet relish before it
gets in the fridge delicious
love sweet relish put it in my tuner
it's great in tuner don't say tuner
tuner shout out tuners
uh yeah i've never done it the worst
thing i did when i was really poor
living in philly in that house you used
to live in i think you were sucking
ketchup packets no i had white rice i
was so poor like no money i remember i
had white rice
and barbecue sauce and i sat there and
ate that just like what am i doing with
my life there had to be something you
that doesn't sound that bad you could
make that work did you have any butter
or garlic salt i don't know it was
[ __ ] 15 years i don't remember every
meal i've ever had and then lie about it
later on
[Laughter]
i know a guy does that do you really
good kid yeah um
no it was just one of those things of
like what do i have i don't have any
money i literally no money and i'm like
[ __ ] white rice is a tough look i was
trying to make that [ __ ] at home and
make that [ __ ] work yeah give me give
me give me a box of pasta any day of the
week oh dude i used to i used to make
salt pepper and olive oil make it work
i'll do what i would do is i would do
uh penne right
al dente
dry
would do
i would do paneer
uh throw some butter like whip you know
i was just before i started eating pasta
sauce
i was a weird man
i was like in my twenties paneer and
peanut butter um
butter
and then uh
some [ __ ] shredded cheese melt that
off
just butter cheese and bread
there'd be there'd be like a soup at the
bottom
of oil yeah
fantastic yeah it's good stuff man uh
never
no i couldn't do it
what the just yes just as a snack
not my kind of thing no
couldn't do it i can eat peanut butter
and jelly with a spoon
i can make that work
sure should i pinch yeah don't be happy
about it yeah you can also lie to
yourself and be like oh well it's
healthy healthier than eating a sandwich
100 percent eaten
when it comes to spoonfuls of things
nothing touches the spoonful of nutella
agreed i'm not a big nutella guy but i
get it sure spoon full of peanut butter
really here i'm a [ __ ] american
spoonful of peanut butter i mean that's
most people can relate to spoonful
peanut butter classic classic spoonful
nutella that's a nice treat yeah i don't
know until it's
it's a little shoddy with me
i did get a bite of a nutella croissant
the other day that my girlfriend had
gotten
that was pretty good they mixed pretty
well
i feel like you got to have something
with nutella
yeah my wife does uh
she makes her own crepes and she'll do
nutella who does my wife really yeah
you're getting crepes at the house yeah
she'll make grapes
palace inking or something it's like a
it's a crepe what does she cook it on
the bottom of the pan the upside upside
down that's how they do it
i don't think so turn the frying pan
upside down and you put it on there and
she just cooks them on the pan really
really really thin and then she'll
[ __ ]
sometimes she'll do she'll like put this
she's sure when she's making she'll make
two different guys she'll make the
nutella
and then she'll make lemon with like
lemon zest and
something it's [ __ ] i like that
bananas bananas
love it
that's what she's doing
nutella
the telling apples all right i just i
was is nutella american no where what is
it european it's your opinion right i
she just i've had it maybe for the first
time like two years ago never heard of
it till [ __ ] like six months ago yeah
that was like commie [ __ ] to me if
someone's like nutella would be like
that's we're not hanging out anymore we
just did didn't cross our [ __ ] radar
yeah that's got russian grocery store
written all over yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's a specialty but it is top shelf
it's awesome it's from italy italy
what are we doing irish shanty irish
people um
let's crank through a couple it was
tough to get my mom to break in the jam
to try to get to try to get her to buy
strawberry preserves some smuckers it
was like you were [ __ ] negotiating a
peace deal yeah we always had that on
stock yeah no it was grape jelly down
the [ __ ] line at my house
you ever have grape jam
i told you peanut butter guys straight
up
maybe a couple of roll gold pretzels on
there my my one cousin growing up well
it's like you're on a chain gang
i love it two big glasses of milk eats
through the plastic bag
it gets hardcore
but i had a cousin growing up i think
until he was probably in his 20s only
ate uh peanut butter and cheese
sandwiches together peanut butter and
american cheese on a roll that's all he
ate
i'm listening i don't hate it
something to kick around you know what
i'll still do from time to time just a
straight up cheese sandwich what the
[ __ ] no [ __ ] idiot yeah just that's a
homer just straight plus it's in your
mouth in about 2.3 seconds it's just
cheese on a rock and a roll [ __ ] yeah
fresh sliced american [ __ ] yeah a couple
out then i throw some chippy some
goldfish whatever we got screaming cold
candy coke
hippies living life oh love a straight
cheese sandwich the best fantastic by
the way the ru garbage cookbook's been
getting kicked around again chatting
with one of one of the fans a little bit
everybody's shitty recipes how nice
would that be maybe make some of them
yeah you want to spearhead that that
sounds like that sounds like [ __ ]
months of work for kevin than to turn
around and split the profits with you do
we know anybody at simon schuster
all right um
let's see here uh
this is all right so these uh one more
from patreon and we'll do we'll knock
out two uh two face bookies uh mrs brown
just joined first question ever have to
put the family pet in the garbage be
when it died because it's too cold to
dig a hole
the family pygmy goat was taken by the
trash company unbeknownst to them
well you got a goat that's a little hook
up a pygmy goat
i'm assuming it's a goat
it looks like a god i mean
i don't know i don't know if you can
tell the demonstration of a pygmy goat
and a regular goat i think for
argument's sake here it's just a goat
dude that is so [ __ ] gross
to know there's a goat in your [ __ ] i
assume it's the outside trash can let's
hope these are the yeah i mean it's not
sitting in the kitchen until till trash
day
no they're they're tiny
the american pygmy is a is an american
pygmy that makes sense right yeah yeah
it is a small compact and stockily built
it'll fit in most
household trash cans now this is crazy
this guy's all right oh it is the little
guy let me see yeah it's just like it
looks like a baby goat like one of those
it's like a dog kind of that's [ __ ] up
you threw it in there that's like
biblical that looks like a baby goat
from like like a jesus painting
nativity scene yeah my my turtles used
to ride these things around
whatever um
yeah that's [ __ ] gross that's bad we
never had we always got we got rid of
the dogs that we had we've thrown in a
tire or two unbeknownst to the trash
people really yeah why is that bad
not what that shrinks why shipping do
you have to go dig it up and i thought
i thought um i think they have to be
recycled properly yeah batteries and and
uh tires have to like car batteries yeah
yeah i mean you throw away a couple
double a's they're not rooting through
that deep
they're not out there [ __ ] opening up
everybody's trash in the cul-de-sac hey
you got a nine volt in here find them
i'm gonna have to write jet protect um
yeah that's nuts but i guess if grounds
froze you got nothing that's all you can
do that's all you can do what the [ __ ]
you know what i mean i i would say
cremation would be the next step go
outside build a fire and you know what i
mean send them off into valhalla or
meatballs
[Laughter]
baby goat meatballs yeah little
meatballs
new pygmy goat meatballs
yeah that's [ __ ]
man think of the trash guy if that would
have spilled open
think about the [ __ ] they see though
holy [ __ ] unbelievable yeah yeah yeah
unbelievable
shout out to the sanitation workers yes
sir all the locals non-locals whatever
you need
i love you
all right uh let's do one or two from
the facebook group here show them a
little like that's the [ __ ] wild west
over there that place oh it's nuts those
guys are bonkers going at it
um
this one [ __ ] general admission dude
get out of there before 6 p.m i'll tell
you that
oh wait this is still from patreon i uh
my apologies from cb did you go to high
school with your aunt uncle niece or
nephew
jesus
bad if there's that overlap i had a
cousin well i mean that's normal normal
yeah normal age range we had
i have i think i've said before i have a
big gap in my family my sister's 21 my
sister was 21 when my youngest brother
was born my youngest half brother that's
just a 20 so technically they could have
that could have happened in my family if
my sister
had a kid
so your brother would be at school with
his niece or nephew yes yikes i grew up
and i grew up one of my buddies in
college
i met him
and his uncle
those are always strange relationships
we hung out to get like they went to we
both they both went to temple live
together those are strange relationships
when people get older when like that's
that's how people slip into becoming
weirdos and like you know just like they
get an apartment together
and they just you know they operate
together sure you know me and my uncle
he's like a year older than you yeah
weird uh-huh yeah it's it's a it's a
weird vibe those are the guys that get
into kidnapping
you're i mean they're getting ripped up
real quick and got to make some bad
choices yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
right
it's true two weird guys driving on a
work van but they don't do anything with
it
no one's working yeah real suspect yeah
uh one more from patreon i forgot a
couple we got a couple of heaters here
uh this is from dan this was big when i
was a kid big big big big
uh ever built anything with stolen wood
oh yeah we've talked about this ramps
construction everything there was there
was a [ __ ]
neighborhood boom in my area yeah they
were selling
foreign [ __ ] mcmansions left and
right and let me tell you something in
the early days they were naive yeah not
even [ __ ] like a a problem now just
[ __ ]
just plywood is as far as that
dude how many times i've been walking
why would you two by fours with like a
[ __ ] the full sheet of plywood with a
buddy like just where we had to walk
like a mile to like the place where the
bike jumps were where we were building a
ford or whatever just like and there
would be like a hammer on top and like a
box of nails that we stole from my
buddies and just
just like two eight-year-olds just
walking with [ __ ] 100 yeah i loved it
these [ __ ] splinters from untreated
plywood oh that'll get you they'll get
you
they'll get you the best bike jump we
ever built was
uh
in this neighborhood they had dumped a
thing of gravel
and uh it was that was there and then so
we were just hitting the gravel because
like after a long time it got like hot
you know it kind of became like one kind
of piece and then it started breaking a
little bit and then we put a piece of
plywood on it like really thin plywood
and that was enough to like do we were
[ __ ]
screaming off this thing dude
oh man we [ __ ] evil commitment he's
at the bottom of a hill so we just
[ __ ] bombed down the hill i mean
looking back it was probably like you
know six inches and we
thought we were catching mega air you
know but as a kid you couldn't tell us
[ __ ] ride down with a parachute on just
in case
yeah kimmy pulled a cord man yeah well
you felt like you know you felt you're
like this is our thing and it was in
this neighborhood that wasn't built and
they would they would stop they would
stop working at like five or whatever
and we would be out of school so we
would like you just had this half built
neighborhood to your [ __ ] self you
ever owned
you ever hang out in the foundation of
an unfinished house
yeah what am i an [ __ ] so trashy dude
the one time we threw uh putting planks
to get down there yeah we threw it
someone would fall a bucket of caulk on
the wall and then just started like
caulking stuff to the wall and we were
[ __ ] [ __ ]
there was a time where we thought like
we cost the [ __ ]
the toll brothers corporation believe
millions we would steal tobaccos and
stuff
it would leave the keys in them it was
wide open i mean we would just like it
would just like jerk or we didn't know
what we were doing you know what i mean
um yeah it was nuts steal the pvc build
like [ __ ] three foot bongs and [ __ ]
we did that we stole the caulk to
[ __ ] caulk it together the fit dude
we did i mean it was like
that was my childhood was just [ __ ]
around the house my one buddy an
unfinished house is just teenage home
depot dude great my one body the smell
of the wood being in there it's [ __ ]
awesome my one buddy [ __ ]
everybody would sneak out at night and
like go smoke we'd like go to the
neighborhood and they'd [ __ ] around
whatever and i wasn't with him but
he was
walking in a house
on the second floor oh it's where you
get into trouble and fell
through
like like he just
whatever is dark out and he fell through
the first floor but the first floor
wasn't finished and he went down into
the foundation
broke his broke his pelvis
and now there's no stairs
to firm to get out of the to get out of
the basement ouch
so i don't i don't know what the [ __ ] is
stephen king though they had a they had
to leave him there and then go like
track down the cop but now you're in
like the middle of a suburban town
there's like probably one cop on at this
time
and they had to let they were like what
were you doing he was like i was
sleepwalking yes
it was
yeah it was like you know the sleeping
pills made me smoke weed and climb in
this [ __ ] construction site
um
all right let's do one from uh let's do
one from facebook this is from adam
snipes have you ever been bitten by fire
ants
because this goes back to you sticking
your nose where it doesn't belong
yeah
those things that those things move
quick and swiftly
yeah
i had one my boy my boy pat got i don't
know if they were fire ants but they
were not normal
hey ants are gonna eat these crackers
because i like an ant i like a regular
ant yeah i'm cool with them aunt tudy
love her auntie but if i see one ant i
don't kill it i don't kill ants no yeah
never but i mean if they got that if
they got that sawdust house cooking i'm
gonna [ __ ] i'm gonna
i'm gonna end a generation if i have to
remember when you were a kid just
looking at those things you'd be like
god just
just wipe them out one of those things
away
it was like dude you don't even have
[ __ ] like a [ __ ] like a flood it's
like there's no studs in here this thing
just [ __ ] a strong window blows man
yeah davis do you ever have an eight
[ __ ] do you ever have an ant farm i
never got it dude somebody mentioned sea
monkeys the other day we i think we've
talked about get the [ __ ] out of here
with those were they alive yeah i don't
know what they were you the trashiest of
all i remember one kid had them for a
while you could like they look a little
shrimp like you could see them
i i don't know what they are
sea monkeys
they're little [ __ ] bugs
oh no i don't [ __ ] with those yeah they
come in like a packet like [ __ ]
it comes like seasoning for ramen
noodles yeah i'm looking at it and you
pour it in and you pour it in water and
they start living yeah they were like
ubiquitous in the sixties and [ __ ] like
that like everything it has
yeah prevalent
he launched it earlier so he's throwing
out big words to get us back i'm trying
to sound smart yeah
uh
yeah no i didn't [ __ ] with that and
forms what about a worm form everybody
in a worm form
yeah
so it looks like it looks like a just
like like a case
like what is this you can't even see
them they're just there
there's no windows there's no glass talk
about being a lonely kid
he needs some bugs crawling around that
you can't even see or talk to
look at the worms yeah check out my
worms yeah um all right let's wrap it up
gang we [ __ ] love you guys today
thank you that was a fun one baby great
episode great family episode we love you
guys uh come out and see a live show
kippy what do you got for him uh just at
cameron comedy on all social media uh we
appreciate all the [ __ ] support you
know we still got some [ __ ] uh some some
merch left so get the cards get the
koozies the whole nine yards do it we
love your gang and we'll see you next
week